[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau c'est 8 le journal voici les
titres
vendredi dernier trois personnalités de
saint quentin en yvelines ont reçu la
médaille d'or de la fédération française
de cyclisme pour leur investissement sur
le dossier du vélodrome nationale nous
étions sur place et puis nous avons
aussi rencontré une troupe de théâtre y
béninoise pas comme les autres en effet
les comédiens jouent à domicile c'est à
dire chez vous un concept qu'ils ont été
en 2011
samedi dernier un atelier robotique
destinée aux enfants de 11 à 15 ans a
été organisée à l'espace yves montand
accueillant pour les enfants ont pu
s'initier à l'électricité au circuit
fermé ou encore à la soudure
c'est désormais officiel une semaine
après sa victoire à la primaire de la
gauche le député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines benoît
hamon a été investi candidat à la
présidentielle par le parti socialiste
devant ses soutiens et des personnalités
du ps réunis à paris l'ancien ministre
de l'éducation a notamment rappelé son
ambition de réunir la gauche
je ne pose pas comme préalable parce que
serait serait la cinquième république
qu'il faut se mettre derrière benoît
hamon le doigt sur la couture du
pantalon et ne rien dire sinon suivre
celui qui est le chef
ça n'est pas ma conception de l'action
politique mais je leur demande
je leur demande en échange
de ne pas me demander des têtes parce
que cela n'a aucun sens le rassemblement
ça ne commence pas par le fait d'exiger
des têtes est le champion des
républicains françois fillon a répondu
lors d'une conférence de presse cet
après midi à ses détracteurs
englué dans une affaire d'emplois
fictifs au bénéfice de sa femme et de
ses deux enfants
françois fillon a notamment confirmé
qu'il irait jusqu'au bout et pourra
compter sur la confiance de ses soutiens
yvelinois écoutez à ce propos suzanne et
blanc président du comité des yvelines
pour françois fillon
oui je suis debout debout et que le
combat continue voilà tout simplement
non comment sa famille et recommence si
on veut peut être que dirait que la
semaine dernière et voilà cet état
n'était pas une évidence
on continue les actions je pense qu'on a
été nombreux à avoir très peur qu'il ne
jette l'épongé
voilà donc c'est pas le cas et bien
autant parfois j'ai eu moi aussi le
moral un peu en baisse autant la voilà
les fous rires les nouveaux selon une
dernière étude pas vu aujourd'hui 68%
des sondés ne veulent plus de l'ex
premier ministre comme candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines ne serait peut-être jamais
sorti de terre sans eux
michèle losier président de saint
quentin en yvelines ainsi que son
prédécesseur robert cadalbert et
l'ancien vice président yves macheboeuf
on bataillait avec la région et l'état
pour créer ce projet pour les remercier
la fédération française de cyclisme a
décidé de les décorer de la médaille
d'or vendredi dernier un reportage de
michael et demi d'euros et de patrick
jacques de dixmude à la fédération
française a organisé ce vendredi 3
février une cérémonie au vélodrome
nationale objectif rendre hommage aux
acteurs politiques saint quentinois qui
ont oeuvré pour la construction de la
structure
michel laugier président de saint
quentin en yvelines ainsi que son
prédécesseur robert cadalbert et
l'ancien vice président yves macheboeuf
ont reçu la médaille d'or des mains du
président de la ffc david lappartient la
médaille d'or et une médaille très
symbolique
il en est remis que 5 par an donc
renforce le poids et la valeur de cette
médaille et c'était important que je
puisse honorer parce que c'est comme moi
qui travaille avec eux recevoir la
médaille d'or de la fédération française
de cyclisme
c'était d'odeurs une odeur qui pour moi
illustre mon investissement que j'ai pu
faire pour l'arrivée de la fédération la
construction du vélodrome
c'est une marque qui me va droit au
coeur parce que effectivement pour nous
à saint quentin en yvelines
l'arrivée de la fédération et donc la
construction de vire drôme était
effectivement dix ans de travail pour
réaliser ce projet les discussions ont
été âpres
les premières réunions ont eu lieu au
début des années 2000 malgré l'échec de
la candidature de paris aux jo de 2012
le projet est maintenu et officiellement
lancé en 2009 pour une livraison en
janvier 2014
coût global des travaux 74 millions
d'euros en partenariat public privé
c'est jamais évident de sortir des
équipements publics de ce niveau là en
plus on arrivait et des périodes comme
ans est difficile et donc il fallait
arriver à bien montrer que globalement
le projet tel qu'il était ficelé tenait
la route tant sur l'aspect de la
réussite sportive mais aussi de son
équilibre avec les manifestations qu'on
pouvait y faire et en même temps prendre
la globalité des besoins que ce soit
pour la fédération mais aussi pour le
territoire
mais la plus belle récompense pour est
arrivé le 13 septembre prochain et club
désignation de la ville hôte pour les jo
de 2024
si le dossier parisien est retenu le
vélodrome accueillera à cette occasion
les épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et le
bmx
depuis octobre le centre de musique
baroque de versailles s'est lancé dans
le projet génération lully le but
permettre aux habitants de trappes de
découvrir l'art baroque dans ce cadre
jeudi dernier des lycéens de l'appel
d'offres ont rencontré un professionnel
et leur a fait découvrir les costumes du
bourgeois gentilhomme de molière
parfois on essaie de quoi donner
l'apparence étrange de voir cette lame
du monde que s'il est plus j'ai parlé de
voir ce matin dans la chambre du roi on
devait beaucoup d'honneur monsieur dans
la chambre du roi un riche bourgeois qui
veut devenir un noble une source de
moquerie pro molière lorsqu'il a écrit
le bourgeois gentilhomme ici monsieur
jourdain et les différents personnages
sont joués par des lycéens de trappes
une découverte de l'importance du
costume de costumes fixant à tacoma
dominicaux c'est sûr que ça ça m'a mené
plus à l'aise par rapport au personnage
ouais ça va être en mieux talent il a
attiré et il a été vraiment dans le
personnage et où ils ont préparé
plusieurs scènes extraites du bourgeois
gentilhomme et les l'exercice étant de
le répéter une fois sans costume blanc
comme dans le cas d'une répétition et
une fois avec les costumes ont des
costumes là
suivi traditionnel interposés mais c'est
historique et de voir tout ce que ça
apportait à la fois pour le public donc
pour ceux qui observait la lire la
pétition et pour les acteurs mis en
place par le centre de musique baroque
de versailles cet atelier s'inscrit dans
le projet génération du lit une
cinquantaine d'élèves ont pu se
familiariser avec l'univers de la
comédie
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'intérêt
surtout pour les costumes parce qu'ils
n'ont pas l'habitude sont quand même des
costumes pas l'habitude de voir ni de
toucher ni manipulée et surtout pas
d'enfiler et donc ils ont été
effectivement très fin très surpris je
pense toucher parce que ça fait partie
d'un certain patrimoine dans le cadre de
génération du lit près de 1000
trappistes sont invités à participer à
ce type de découverte une action
éducative artistique et culturelle qui
va durer jusqu'en 2018
et on continue encore avec du théâtre
avec cette initiative originale d'une
troupe pas comme les autres en effet ces
comédiens jouent uniquement à domicile
c'est à dire chez vous lancez un peu par
hasard en 2011
le concept se fait connaître grâce au
bouche à oreille
voici une pièce de théâtre sans théâtre
ce décor n'est autre que le chaleureux
salon d'un couple de montigny le
bretonneux le temps d'une soirée les
habitants ont payé chez eux les
comédiens de la troupe vu sur scène
j'aime jouer chez les gens parce que
c'est une pièce qui est assez intimiste
et donc le décor se prête tout à fait ou
au thème de la pièce qui est une
réflexion du couple sur son devenir
les comédiens denis tison et catherine
germain incarnent un couple de
sexagénaires au bord de l'ennui
alors que leurs enfants viennent de
quitter le nid familial les laissant
seuls en face à face
t'es pas content aujourd'hui si j'ai
envie de passer à autre chose
j'ai peur de m'ennuyer
[Musique]
tu as commencé à l'ennui quand on joue
le public est à trois mètres c'est à
dire qu'on le sent on sent sa
respiration
ça change totalement la conception du
théâtre classique m'a complètement huit
clos dans un salon cette pièce intitulée
bleu caramel se prête bien à ce genre
d'expérimentations mais ne vous y
trompez pas il y a bien mis en scène
on utilise mieux tel qu'il est
idéalement on se dirait à ça serait bien
que la cuisine est ce soit donc ce qu'on
appelle au jardin au théâtre à dire sur
la gauche de l'image si elle est à
droite ça on fera avec la droite et donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont un petit temps
de répète sur place pour reprendre leurs
marques
ce soir là les fonds ont été reversés à
l'association l'accord des franciliennes
dont s'occupe catherine je trouve que
c'est vraiment une idée à développer à
ça fait passer un bon moment ensemble et
c'est ça sort un petit peu beaucoup même
de l'ordinaire à la fin de la pièce les
comédiens accepte volontiers de partager
un moment de convivialité
alors n'hésitez plus la troupe se
produit dans toute la france
trois personnes condamnées à rester
ensemble pour l'éternité c'est une
oeuvre incontournable de la littérature
française huis clos de jean paul sartre
est à redécouvrir sur scène la troupe
scrap enscène originaire de trappes se
produit tous les samedis jusqu'au 18
février dans un théâtre parisien
nous sommes allés rencontrer la
compagnie en pleine répétition à la
maison des familles à trappes
inès estelle et garcin et le garçon nous
sommes tous les trois morts nous
arrivons en enfer bon c'est pas trop ce
que je suis nous les grooms très vite
ils vont bien voir qu'il ne se
supportent pas mais il va bien falloir
quand même faire avec et ils ont tous
fait quelque chose de répréhensible qui
cependant faire mais quoi elle va
falloir l'avouer pour pour se comprendre
et essayer de de se supporter les uns
les autres et donc l'enfer c'est les
autres c'est la pièce célèbre sam 16h
sans cesse de triangle infernal en fait
où on ne peut pas on ne peut pas s'en
sortir salle en fait on est ensemble ou
pas c'est nous trois horaires la ville
de guyancourt a organisé samedi dernier
un atelier destiné aux jeunes entre 11
et 15 ans sur la robotique à l'espace
yves montand notre journaliste nicolas
landry était sur place
construire un véhicule à deux roues ou
robotisée c'est le défi de ses cinq
petits ingénieurs en herbe ils
participent à un atelier consacré à la
robotique à l'espace yves montand de
guyancourt découpage assemblage soudure
ils ont pu découvrir les différentes
étapes de construction
j'ai appris à faire de la soudure
travail que les engrenages ce que
j'avais jamais fait encore il ya faire
des des conduits d'électricité
c'est la première fois que j'ai fait de
la soudure et est aussi un robot j'ai
appris ce que j'étais un robot aussi à
différencier des robots a d'autres moi
j'aime bien suis vraiment d'emploi et
construire j'aime beaucoup construire
animatrice de l'association planète
sciences clémence encadrent cet atelier
en détaillant le vocabulaire technique
de la mécanique et de l'électricité et
en les accompagnant dans le montage et
après tu révises l'association planète
sciences rempli plusieurs objectifs à
travers ses activités ludiques et
pédagogiques et sensibiliser déjà à la
robotique au robot parce qu'on sait que
ça fait de plus en plus partie de notre
environnement de dans notre société tout
simplement et
aussi ça leur permet bien de s'éveiller
aussi à manipuler expérimentés comment
construire vraiment un véhicule un
nouvel atelier pourrait être organisée
autour des capteurs et des logiciels
pour concevoir un véritable robot et
c'est là fort de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivis prochaine édition
demain à 18 heures et surtout bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]